now there's a stark link between obesity
and dying from covert 19 according to
new research
the report by the world obesity
federation shows that excess weight
is second only to age as factors when it
comes to the death toll
ninety percent of deaths from covert 19
are from countries with high rates of
obesity
that's 2.2 million out of the total 2.5
million
killed it shows that mortality rates are
10 times higher
where at least 50 percent of the
population is overweight so that
includes
the us italy and the uk now on the other
end of the scale it shows
no single country where less than 40
percent of the population was overweight
has a high death rate
well we can now speak to johanna ralston
she's the chief executive of the wild
obesity federation and she joins us now
from boston massachusetts joanna thanks
for taking the time to be with us
i want to start with the science behind
this how do we explain
this correlation how sure are we
well the facts are the facts that we've
mapped out the uh the high court
the high correlation between um obesity
between cover death rates and
countries with high rates of obesity
similarly we've seen in those countries
with with as you said low levels of uh
covert death rates low rates of obesity
so that's just what it is and we know
that there's
uh factors including sort of the
inflammatory response other factors that
are still really emerging
um that are that are sort of uh have a
causal relationship but also there's
associated factors like level of public
health policy level of adherence to
recommendations and guidelines
that probably play in as well we already
know that poorer communities
often minority communities are the ones
who are likely to be potentially eating
more poorly and therefore becoming more
obese
so is this partly why we've seen such a
disproportionate toll on those groups
and places
like the united states and the uk
absolutely in places where the
availability of of healthier foods is
is much less in in poorer communities
it's been called in the past
food deserts that definitely is a
contributory factor and we're actually
seeing that all over the world
people living in lockdown and
unfortunately in some cases some
aggressive and unfortunate marketing by
uh by food companies but the reality is
that often
um unhealthier foods are cheaper than
their
healthier counterparts as well and so
these are all factors but obesity is not
driven by any one factor it's driven by
multiple factors so
food food plays a critical role
particularly ultra processed food but
there's also other there's genetics
there's a predisposition family history
and uh even access to uh to places safe
places for physical activity
which again are fewer in poorer
communities um joanna we were just
mentioning that obviously age
has come across as the biggest factor in
terms of covert mortality risk but i see
your report puts obesity second
so how do we tackle this is obesity then
considered an underlying condition
should it be for prioritized
vaccinations for instance
we do believe that people with obesity
should be prioritized for for
vaccinations and uh
and that indeed that is happening um
sort of in a
somewhat fragmented way around the world
um absolutely the the health concerns
and conditions
quite frequently people with obesity do
have other diseases
in addition to obesity and that would
include diabetes cardiovascular disease
cancer but but not
not solely so it's absolutely people
that obesity need to be prioritized for
the vaccine
well if crovid 19 is around to stay as
many experts suggest that it will be
this is clearly more reason yet to
tackle the broader obesity epidemic now
given the disparity in incomes and
access to nutrition that we were also
speaking about earlier how do we do that
well it's not just so so um it's not
just access nutrition it's also access
to health care i think it's
understanding obesity
as a disease on par with diabetes which
is both a risk factor and a
and a disease in its own right and so
that in the health care systems and
particularly in primary care in
every part of the world it's understood
that obesity is a is a health condition
that requires treatment
the treatment can include uh nutrition
it can also include physical activity it
can include
uh you know pharmacological products it
can include uh surgery and
in uh which are which are slightly more
costly um interventions but certainly
possible in many environments
so it's really understanding it as a as
a as a disease not that's not meant to
be
stigmatized which is unfortunately
currently the case in many parts of the
world
but in fact a disease that should be
treated just uh just like any other
disease
with a variety of approaches um there's
many drivers of rgc
obesity and therefore the solutions are
manifold as well and at world obesity
federation
and with our colleagues around the world
we've developed a root strategy which
stands for sort of the five pillars of
an effective and comprehensive approach
joanna ralston there the chief executive
of the world obesity federation
thanks so much for joining us here on al
jazeera thanks for your time joanne
thank you so much